hey set of files welcome back to the
annual super bowl edition of the instant
trailer of you I'm Jes and I'm David and
we're going to talk about all the cool
movie spots we saw during the Super Bowl
a lot of big superhero stuff captain
america the winter soldier spider-man
two transformers not really super hero
but we the first footage we've ever seen
of this new age of extinction film yeah
let's talk about that what did you think
of the 0 and get transformers I thought
was great we see Dinobots I think my
favorite shot was when Optimus Prime
takes out a sword while riding a
dinosaur I'm not sure what kind of
dinosaur like what what the name of its
good but it looked cool some type of
t-rex tide yeah that's supposed to come
out July I'd like it's coming out this
summer you're a big transformers yeah I
didn't really like the second or third
movie but I'm glad that they're sorry
rebooting it almost mark wahlberg now
and then what'd you think of the amazing
spider-man 2 stuff I mean we
spider-knight showcasing the enemies
looked and right so the great thing
about that is they showed when Stacy
falling and getting caught by swagger
man but she doesn't die and that's right
she's even wearing the same sort of
outfit she's supposed to wear in the
comics when she died so I feel like that
was almost like a spoiler so it's like
they just ruined a little bit of the
movie by doing that but I like so far
there's another trailer that came out
with electro I think it's called the
enemies you learn at it is unite com
actually just watch it on our Channel
that's a better idea there's a lot
changing from the first movie but like
even the score is now going to be
different Hans Zimmer's doing the score
instead of james horner the costumes
different but we still have a lot the
same cast same director which is good
but they seem to put a lot of emphasis
on electro and they still haven't shown
much of the Rhino we haven't seen or
heard from Paul Giamatti really in the
trailers and we know the green Goblin's
in it but we don't seem to see any
transformation moments let's talk about
the other superhero film and that's
Captain America Winter Soldier yeah um I
mean it's pretty similar to the first
trailer we got I mean not a whole lot of
new stuff yeah well we see a little bit
more of like of the winter soldier and a
little bit more action from Scarlett
Johansson we also see more of the
Falcons so that's cool but oh the plot
wise it's pretty much the same we're
seeing a lot of the same stuff need for
speed this is now one of my favorite TV
spots
and it's it's just all visuals and the
engines revving yeah i love the editing
of that is so interesting just like a
root like the brooming becomes its own
rhythm and really kind of makes me more
excited to the movie yeah I I thought it
was a gorgeous spot I'm definitely
looking forward to that um those were
the four probably biggest ones going
along kind with that is Noah we have
another TV spot which again was just
snippets from the trailers nothing
really i think this one we saw a little
more of the angels supposedly there was
like One whistles yeah six wing good
things that I I really don't know who
this movies for at this point yeah I did
write about him I for everyone in this
can be for no one what did you think
about this TV spot Super Bowl spot that
we got for a million ways to die in the
west it's basically Seth MacFarlane and
Ted so it's basically Seth MacFarlane
talking to himself yeah because he he's
even the same it's the Peter Griffin
voice for the the bear that's true um
it's interesting that he's using that
movie to promote a new movie because
they're not really connected that that
movie was a huge box office I guess I
guess that would be why why yeah but I
thought it was clever because they're
just saying you know this movie has a
lot of content that's not okay for TV so
go to their website to check it out
alright so that's our coverage for last
night's big TV spots let us know in the
comments below which TV spot was your
favorite and which film you're most
looking forward to i'm jay s and i'm
david thanks for watching